[Music]
there's nothing like watching a movie
get done the old-fashioned way from the
deepest reaches of space to a whole lot
of fake vomit there are some effects
that a computer just can't replicate
some of your favorite movies TV shows
and even music videos got ambitious in
2018 here are the 10 coolest practical
effects of 2018 the prehistoric
Megalodon of course was a work of CGI
but a lot of the damage the shark caused
was not in one scene they actually roll
the boat over and while a lot of the
movie wasn't actually shot in the open
ocean
the cast still had to do a lot of work
underwater in a massive tank in New
Zealand
[Music]
the Jurassic franchise has a history of
seamlessly mixing CGI and practical
effects fallen kingdom was no exception
blue the heroic Velociraptor came to
life in a few scenes in the form of an
animatronic and in some scenes as a
puppet meanwhile the legendary t-rex was
also there on set to prepare for the
scene Bryce Dallas Howard actually had
to learn how to ride the immense
creature and while the Indo Raptor was a
mostly CGI creature a mechanical head
and arm were created to properly terrify
the cast
[Music]
[Applause]
this masterful superhero entry went all
out to create its villain kill monger
played by Michael B Jordan the actor was
covered in around 3000 prosthetic dots
in addition the River tribe elder
characters were given prosthetic lip
plates
the Star Wars saga has a storied history
of using practical effects to capture
the Kessel run in solo a simulator
became a stand-in for the deepest
reaches of outer space screens
surrounding the ship projected moving
images of hyperspace many of those shots
amazingly were good enough that they
actually ended up in the movie on set
this all looks something like an
amusement park ride
[Music]
the basketball comedy based off a
popular Pepsi commercial turned several
current and former NBA stars into old
men
Kyrie Irving went through hours of
makeup and prosthetic work to play the
titular character as did Shaq Reggie
Miller and Nate Robinson one of the
unique challenges for the movies makeup
artist was to ensure that the makeup
didn't fall right off the actors faces
during the basketball scenes one of the
year's funniest gross-out comedies went
all out for its most disgusting gag for
a scene involving communal projectile
vomit the special effects team got the
cast to actually puke well sort of they
made a smoothie like concoction of fake
vomit the actors then spit it out
through tubes attached to their mouths
Pixar might have turned the entire world
towards computer animation but
traditional forms of animating haven't
disappeared stop-motion isn't going
anywhere
early man made by the team best known
for Wallace and Gromit
use claymation to bring prehistoric
times to life a team of 23 model makers
brought 273 puppets to life with each
individual puppet taking more than 10
weeks to make Wes Anderson's second
stop-motion feature
following the masterful fantastic mr.
Fox was equally eye popping and even
more ambitious than his earlier film
while fantastic mr. Fox had about 370
puppets they're working with 1105
puppets in Isle of Dogs many of the
puppets were covered in fur which
provides a unique challenge to
stop-motion animators
it makes it harder to replace the
four-legged characters facial
expressions
fracture defects the special effects
team behind much of West world season
two did a stellar job this year
among their most impressive feats we're
the drone hosts Maeve's grizzly neck
wounds and a samurai host who lost part
of his head
[Music]
this year ariana grande elevated both
her songs and the music videos that
accompanied them to a whole new level
this was especially evident in the music
video for her hit song no tears left to
cry in the music video she rotates
around a spinning hallway to pull this
off they actually built a massive
rotating corridor in addition grande
also had to get a life cast done so they
could create multiple masks of her face
some of it of course he's a little bit
of computer-generated wizardry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you